hey guys I'm a lot of which are Lanza
and I have a puppy
what are you doing her name is Chelsea
and she's 11 weeks old and she likes to
fight my hair but she actually also but
everything else like my hand right now
are you doing but I feel like it's kind
of okay because she's so cute
and she's a chocolate lab and we bought
I think a week ago
ah oh we want to say hello what's that
is it you know it's just my face again
can you bite again there at this is
great
would you would you try to do she is
especially cute though because she just
freaking loves every single person she
meets you just like runs up to them and
wants to be their best friend including
my cat which doesn't work so well
because he's not quite as interested so
sometimes she'll like try to approach
him and then hiss at her and she'll get
standing away and then there's just a
lot of like standoffs where they're both
just staring at each other waiting for
the other one to move
so I kind of don't really like the name
Chelsea so I've been calling her
Chauncey instead and I don't think
anyone's realized so it's basically like
I have my own secret Pokemon
but I guess that's it for me today
everyone not much else to say about this
puppy except that she's super cute and
still chewing things because that's like
90% of what she goes I'll see you guys
next time okay I mean she's not paying
any attention to me at all right now but
the fact that I have a puppy just
casually sitting on my lap makes me feel
like some kind of God